Heads up everybody. There's going to
be Japanese pronunciations in this one.
I'm not Japanese. I don't always get
it at 100% right. I do try though.
Let's get into it.
On march the 20th 1995 five
members of Japan's Aum,
Shinrikyo cult boarded to the Tokyo
subway in the middle of rush hour.
That's ATM.
They punctured bags of Seren releasing
a deadly cloud of nerve gas into the
crowded trains. Commuters were
blinded, racked with spasms,
some choke to death on their own blood
trapped underground with no, it's run.
Some 6,000 people were aghast at
bright spring day and 13 of them died.
The attack was ordered by omes founder
Yoga Instructor Shakara I Sahara a blinds
mistake.
100 had leveraged his intense personal
charisma into massive wealth creating a
religious embar worth $1 billion,
but where most of Angeles use
their money to build churches.
I Sohara used his to build an Ami under
his watch on stockpile of chemical
weapons.
They bred deadly viruses.
They infiltrated the Japanese authorities
purchasing attack, helicopters,
building weapons of mass destruction and
drawing up plans to destroy the worlds.
They were the single most ambitious
cult that has ever existed and they
committed all of their crimes while
hiding in plain sight. In the video today,
the remarkable story of the man who
nearly brought about Armageddon,
one of the overriding features of these
videos is just how many of us subjects
come from humble circumstances.
Shocker Sahara,
he was born new difference born in the
Kumomoto prefecture or on March the
second 1955 he was one of
just nine children that his
poor mother bore pour in.
This case does have a double meaning.
Aside from all that childbirth,
they were totally broke.
All of their income came from their Dad's
part time work as a traditional weaver,
which was barely enough to support
a one man, let alone a large family,
but that's a horror at this point.
It's still known by his birth name,
Cheese Matsumoto. He adds an
additional disadvantage. He was blinds.
One Eye's vision was completely
gone while the others was impaired,
shipped off to a state run school for
the blind's. It's only six years old.
The young boy seemed destined
by fate for hardship.
Only faith doesn't count it on one
thing as a horror, as charisma,
ferociously intelligence as a horror
was noted by his teachers for the almost
demagogic sway that he had over other
students. His voice was like a weapon,
but that was something else that
is teachers noted to, as a horror,
had a violence side hurting others. It
was something of a game. Damn one SAS,
a horror had decided you were the enemy.
He would do everything in
his power to make you suffer.
Despite these early
warnings, though, shocker,
graduated in 1975 with all the
trappings of a deeply ordinary man,
he failed the tests to get into law and
medical school and settled for studying
acupuncture, relocating to Cheba
Prefecture, just south of Tokyo.
He opened his own practice selling
medicines and that was kind of it,
at least for a few years.
And 1978 as a horror married his
sweetheart Tomako to settle down to making
babies.
Even as a horror is conviction.
In 1982 for selling fake cures couldn't
shake how fundamentally boring as life
was. However, things were about
to get very, very interesting.
In the early 1980s Japan's economy had
become the single biggest on earth.
With this expansion, it came a
tidal wave of soulless consumerism.
The results of this was a generation
of Japanese desperate to locate some
meaning in their lives.
So the beginning around 1980 a whole
load of new religion started cropping up.
So you feed the wealthy nations,
impoverished sols,
and one of these was Aegon shoe.
It makes your of Buddhism and Hinduism,
they go on to shoe,
had been around since 1954 but it's
popularity excluded when the government
recognized it as an official religion
in 1981 like thousands of others.
Shocker Asara was sucked in by its
teachings becoming a devout member.
But rather than gaining enlightenment,
I Sohara gained something even better.
He got an idea like an American rubber
baron watching the first piece of
railroad track being laid
as a Horah divine's the new
religions where the future
ends. Well, he wanted a piece of the
action, so he left. I go on a shoe,
the engineer had a spiritual crisis that
allows them to a Benz and Tomoko and
the children and go to India for
two years to study religious texts.
When he finally returned in 1994 he was
ready in some time without Yass a horror
founded own Shinzen.
No Chi quickly renamed alm Shinrikyo he
changed his name to shock and awe Sohara
and it's began handing out leaflets on
Tokyo street corners and preaching his
new religion. So there's a blinds,
men NOCONA shouting about gold.
Surely the busy people of Tokyo would
have just laughed at him and walked on.
Right? Well, not exactly
do remember the shock.
Jasa Haro was one of the most
charismatic talkers ever born.
A guy who could even give Hitler
a run for his money like it.
He's soon put his go to
given gift to diabolical use.
So at this point we really
need to ask ourselves what,
what was on Shinrikyo when,
what did they believe? Well,
it's actually kind of hard to say now.
Officially the religion was a Knicks
of Christianity, End Times theology,
Hindu creation myths and Buddhism,
Yoga and Nostradamus, his prophecies.
Well apparently whatever else that's
a harder had lying around beneficially
though.
Um,
had it one tenant making us a
horror king as devise virus,
a hierarchy and structure was designed
to make him rich while quickly and
effectively brainwashing everyone
that the cults got its claws into like
Scientology, at forced members to pay
for access to higher spiritual plane,
often making people sign over their
entire fortunes. Unlike Scientology,
it also put it in Steve Ots
through extreme pain designed
to break their will on
rituals. They ranged on a scale
of just plain nuts to holy hell.
What hell is going on?
Followers were made to drink as a
harbor is blood and daddy bath water.
They underwent ordeals of being
plunged into boiling water.
It's a purifying their souls,
the practice that led to many
burns and even one death.
Some were locked up in isolation. Rooms
for days on end of us were force fed,
hallucinogenic drugs.
Above all this floated.
The specter of us are Horab sometimes
literally follow is believed he could
levitate for hours at a time and that
he was capable of reading their minds.
They revered him as a living go onto
reincarnation of Christ or Buddha and the
Hindu god of destruction.
Lord Shiva all rolled into some sort
of Super God given now utterly bizarre.
All of this,
as you might expect to hear that home
attracted a few hundred loonies are best,
but oh boy, would you be wrong. As a
horror, he was a gifted. Advertise them.
He recruited only from the upper middle
classes of Japanese society targeting
the well qualified and rich giving
only the aura of an exclusive club,
albeit one that would a robe.
You blinds as Omega three rich,
it's reaching creased, sucking in
more of the young and alienated.
It helps that 1986 markets at
the start of the bubble economy.
When Japan became phenomenally wealthy,
not that own was confined to Japan.
Influential Russians began to
join as the decades dragged home.
Even Germans who were recruited
and send American Brown shape,
and by the late 1980s own was perhaps
the biggest of Japan's new religions.
As a Haro was surrounded by 10,000 devoted
followers on compounds that sprawled
outside of Tokyo and in skyscrapers
rented downtown, I would leave.
He told the public he was a new guru
spreading a peaceful message in private.
He told his confidence that one day
he would be the king of Japan as his
influence grew as a hauler is
bullying ways they were sentenced.
He still owns it, forcing own members to
practice extortion and even kidnapping.
There in relatives, friends, some money.
This is money was laundered through a
network of yoga centers and computer shops
that the group established with the
help of the Yakuza and 1999 the Tokyo
metropolitan government. It finally
granted the religion legal status,
even as a horror,
began preaching antisemetic conspiracy
theories and saying Americans must be
kills. Some said that and
infiltrated the government itself,
bending the law to it's well as the
sun on Japan's most hedonistic decade.
That's a horror was in
a pretty good place.
He was rich with the religion worth
a cool one, billion American dollars.
He was also worshiped by
thousands of people about that.
It wasn't enough for the poor
boy from Kumamoto Prefect jet.
He wanted to rule millions and he
didn't care if he had to kill to make as
squalor dreams come true.
It started with our eyes.
It was 11:00 PM on June the 27th of 1994
Yoshiyuki conoce wife began complaining
of vision problems.
The Kona is where a typical Japanese
upper middle class couple of living in the
leafy kg height suburb of Madison,
Modo surrounded by doctors and lawyers
and judges that they fall night though
the security of their expensive
neighborhood. It didn't save them,
barely had Yoshiyuki guns
and check on his wife.
Then she fell to the ground suffering
spasms and foaming at the mouth as the
salesman panics. Little did he
knew that all across their street,
others were collapsing to dying
before their loved one's eyes.
In all that commotion, No one
noticed the van driving quietly away.
The van was registered to arm Shinrikyo.
This van I saw horror had
ordered modifying to emis
clouds of deadly nerve gas,
the 1994 and that's a moto incident,
killed eight people and left 500 injured.
It was the first major terrorist action
by Oh and the first terrorist attack
ever carried out with siren,
but it didn't come from nowhere.
Over the last half decade.
Ahmed metamorphosed from Amea Doomsday
cults into one of the most dangerous
terrorist organizations on earth.
The Ross had started back in 1989
just as Tokyo was recognizing it isn't
official religion.
That February,
a young man named Shuji tag Gucci hat
trying to leave the cult rather than let
them go as a horror,
ordered him strangled to death.
No long off relatives of all members
that banded together to find a police
complaints.
A young lawyer named Tsutsumi sack a moto
took the case and lead to disappear in
November,
along with his wife and their newborn
baby at laser emerge that all members had
beaten all three of them to death
and buried their bodies in a forest.
When police investigated home sympathizers
on the force destroyed evidence that
could have convicted as a horror by
now as a whole row was on his way to
becoming a Japanese. Charles Manson
completes with a dodgy bid and hack us,
but one event was about to send him
further into murderous insanity.
This even Manson could
have only dreamed of.
In February,
1990 Japan went to the polls to elect a
new governments as Sohara made sure 24
own members were on the ballot.
This would be the first step in his
plan to become king once Almaden to the
Japanese Diet that you know,
stopping them.
That was just one tragic flaw with this.
The public did not like
option Rikkyo one little bit.
When the results came in Ohms,
24 candidates at scraped together a
lousy 1,700 votes given mom had nearly 10
times as many adherence.
This was a seriously pathetic
outcome. Overnight as a,
I became the laughing stock of Tokyo.
Now in an ideal,
well this is where as a
horror story would end,
but here's the thing about
laughingstocks humiliating them.
It's rally the ends as the
often misattributed quote
goes first they ignore you,
then they laugh at you, then
they fight you, then you win.
And with his dreams of being
king shattered as a horror,
it was now ready to fight.
He started by modifying his prophecies.
He now told followers the
world would end the following,
a chemical weapon attack in 1995 evac job
when I was to make that attack happen.
So alm change tack,
they began using members who worked in
government labs to stockpile botulism
anthrax.
They sent a team to Zaire,
now the Democratic Republic of
the Congo to collected Bola.
They started selling illegal drugs,
fund their activities,
hiring the Yakuza to provide the muscle.
Within two months of the elections,
all launched their first
attack using the modified van.
The group released botulism into the
air outside of the Japanese Diet.
The attack fails because they used a
harmless strain pattern that would repeat
two years later when they tried to spray
anthrax over Tokyo from the top of a
skyscraper.
Unfortunately,
the same couldn't be said for their
experiments with Seran back in.
Kc Hides the Asha you could
call know called the police,
begging them to save his wife.
Instead they arrested him and charged him
with using Seren to killers, neighbors.
We can only imagine how as a higher must
have laughed to himself when he heard
the news.
It was in 1994 and only seemed invincible
in the nine months between the Matsumoto
incidents and the Tokyo subway attack.
Ohm went certifiably insane by now.
The group was convinced
doomsday was mayor months away,
that the world was out to get them and
that they needed to act fast to bring
about the apocalypse.
The tails of that time are so crazy
that that seemed like fantasy.
If we didn't know that they were true.
There's the way I'm set up his own factory
dedicated to producing AK 47 the way
they managed to steal plans
for constructing tanks
and heavy artillery from a
military contractor the way
they successfully smuggled
and attack helicopter
into Japan from Russia as his army
ants. Fire power grew, so did us.
A horror is boldness.
In late 1994 he ordered the
assassination of an ex cultist with VX,
the same chemical weapon used by North
Korea to assassinate Kim Jong moons
dissident brother.
In 2017 in February of 1995 he ended
at Japanese official kidnaps and
incinerated alive and a specially built
oven that same month he ordered his
troops do summarily executed nine old
members. He suspected of disloyalty.
All nine were hanged and coordinators
with the ashes being thrown in a lake,
and believe me,
it gets even crazier.
In 1993 Ahmed purchased a ranch in
Australia that was home to a uranium mine.
By 1994 they were actively planning to
extract the uranium and build a dirty
bomb.
There's even some evidence the cults
plan to attack in New York's World Trade
Center.
In short,
I'm in early 1995 was a military fighting
force prepared to do battle and die
for that leader with Japanese authorities
still turning a blind eye to the group.
They could probably have carried out any
number of atrocities that, as a horror,
hadn't forgotten his prophecy.
He had said five days ago that the world
would end with chemical weapons and
knew how to make it happen.
Now it's on their Australian ranch.
Cultists for all of them had been testing
increasingly deadly types of siren on
sheep. As production moved
to that Japanese compounds,
the group now had enough of the Nazi
nerve gas to kill millions of people.
They just needed somewhere to release it,
to bring about the apocalypse and
that's somewhere was of course the Tokyo
subway in March of 1995 as a horror
took five of his followers aside as Eg
Hirosi Toro, Toyota Masato
Yaki Yammer. Yes, who you are.
Hi Yoshi and decor you
high listened attentively.
That master spelled out his grand plan
in a few days' time old within the world
and they would have the honor of being
as a horror is five horsemen of the
apocalypse.
7:30 AM on March the 20th 1995
30 year olds can eg Hirosi.
You got on board to the Tokyo subway
is Marinucci line headed for Sucky Igi
station,
a shy young man with the Dorky pair of
glasses and as an umbrella cluttered in
one hands.
No one paid any attention to him as he
took a seat and placed a plastic bag on
the floor shortly before 8:00 AM is the
train ends at the government districts.
Hirosi calmly tapped his umbrella twice,
puncturing his plastic bag.
He got up and Texas is vanishing
into the morning muscle.
Just another face in the anonymous
Tokyo crowd across the subway network.
Toyota Yaka Yammer ruins
the too high he she is.
We're doing the exact same thing.
It never even occurred to
anyone to stop them as heroes.
He's trained lurched off
to its next destination.
Someone noticed a funny smell,
chemical whiff as the train rolled on,
commute is trapped inside,
began to fill ill to notice
them vision and giving funny.
By the time it pulled
in to the next station,
it was clear that something
was seriously wrong as Esea.
2:00 AM the first alarm went up on
the heavier line drain poisoned by.
So hey you,
she people were vomiting blood.
Others were having fits as the news
of the problem reached the subway
authorities.
They made a fateful decision.
They decided to shut
down the effective lions.
The results was Sarah unfilled trains
becoming stuck between stations,
the people on board traps and
like wraps and a deadly box.
As the gas seeps out to
fill first cars then trains.
Hundreds of people were poisons and
then thousands with nowhere to run.
Survivors panicked,
desperately trying to escape death in
those black and claustrophobic tunnels.
At one station,
three subway employees bravely tried
to remove a Sarah and package by hands
within minutes. Two of them were dad.
As commuters ran for the surface.
They brought the siren with them,
clinging to their clothes like a disease.
It spread from person to person poisoning.
Thousands more bodies piled up in
the streets outside of stations.
Paramedics who ran to treat the
wounded were themselves affected.
That nervous systems attacked
by an invisible killer.
In that morning's carnival of Horace Mann,
he would go blinds.
Many would suffer brain damage and many
would die. It was the bloodiest day.
Japan's capital.
How to work in too.
Since the firebombing of
Tokyo in 1945 at that moment,
it must have really seems like the end
of the world are truly arrived. Luckily,
he has a horror. He had already
seen the seeds of its own downfall.
Do you remember that whole Matsumoto
incident from about five minutes ago when
own poison, that entire
suburb with Seran? Well,
Hiroshi Merita had been on the front
lines treating that attack and had since
become Japan's leading authority
on Sarah and poisoning.
When news broke from Tokyo about a
mysterious gas poisoning commuters,
he immediately put two and two
together with frightening speed.
He frantically called in,
faxed every single hospital in Tokyo,
sending them detailed instructions
for treating Seren poisoning.
Since Aaron can take hours
to kill or disable you,
it's thought of Marita's actions
saved many lives, but not all of them.
By the time the sunsets on Japan's
Day of terror, 12 people would debt,
dozens have been permanently disabled
and somewhere in the region of 6,000
people had been poisoned
10 years after the attack.
It would be estimated that
around 30% of those injured,
we're still suffering with the
effects of Sarah and poisoning.
One study claimed that 60% of those
gas experienced permanent damage for
Japanese authorities. The Tokyo
subway attack. It was a wake up call.
There was no longer any
doubt to there's um,
we're involved in to know amounts of
friends in the police could save a Sahara.
Now it was time to take down the cultist
the days after on siren attack.
We're living through a dream less than
48 hours after Kenichi Hirosi punctured
his bag of Seren, a series of coordinated
police raids, saw alm, compounds rated,
and 200 cultists arrested facilities
for producing Seren mustard gas.
Anthrax and Vieques was seized along with
enough weapons to start a war shocked
by the southern police attention. The
cult hit back hard. On march the 30th,
the head of the National Police Agency
was shot and nearly killed mine home
assassin.
Two weeks later to sympathize sympathizers
released a cloud of fostering gas at
the Oklahoma station,
injuring 400 people.
But it wasn't until may the fifth that
I'm really trying to get their revenge.
That morning of cyanide bomb was left
below, add dockets in some Juku station.
There was enough gas in it to kill
20,000 people through shift fluke,
the designator malfunctions and it
wouldn't be Tokyo's lost and miss. Well,
may the 16th 1995 [inaudible] was finally
found hiding inside of fake wall and
oms headquarters. Although he was
arrested, the attacks didn't stop.
His 13 year old daughter Rico was made
leader and instituted a reign of shocking
abuse and torture that surpassed
even a father that same evening,
and I'm not a bomb,
nearly killed the governor of Tokyo.
Finally on July the fourth 1995 not four
months after the subway attack ohms,
last gasp came for hydrogen.
Cyanide bombs were left and
subway stations across Tokyo.
Together they would have killed somewhere
in the region of 100,000 people,
but once again, those detonators
failed broken by repeated raids.
Their teenage dictator now taken
into care on scattered the groups,
high ranking members. They all went on
the run scattering to the four winds.
The last fugitive member
wouldn't be captured until
2000 and 12,000 [inaudible].
It was the end of the line.
Has Trial began in 1996 just as the
one rich on declared bankruptcy.
It lasted an incredible eight years
for the first four years as a higher ed
disrupted proceedings by making long,
rambling speeches,
claiming a miracle would see them.
That's even as legendary charisma.
It couldn't help him.
Now in 2000 to Sro seemed to
recognize this and do you fell silent.
He wouldn't speak again
for the rest of his life.
In 2004 as a hydro is finally sentenced
to death by hanging is law has failed to
file appeals,
and in 2006 the sentence was upheld.
Not Two years later as a horror
had a sort of mental collapse.
He stopped all contact with
his family and followers.
He stopped eating and that's,
he was spoonfed.
He refused to use the toilets and
instead took to wearing an adult diaper,
soiling himself in silence in
a gloomy corner of his cell,
defeated and forgotten.
He stayed like that for the next decade.
On July the sixth 2018 God's
led as a horror from his cell.
Now it's into the yards alongside
six other armed cultists,
so he hadn't seen for 12 years.
It's impossible to know what the other
cultists fell. Seeing him in that moment,
seeing the man who'd ones bend to
them and off of Tokyo, to his will,
reduced to a silent living corpse.
Do they feel remorse?
Did they see him for the false gods
that he always was? We'll never know.
All seven were hangs that morning.
Their families only alerted
after they were already dead.
They were cremated inside the prison.
Their bodies burned is that once burned,
those of their victims,
when news of [inaudible] death reached
the media and most living outside of
Japan kind of just shrugged and
we're like, who? Yes. Even now,
his story,
it might not be over in 2000 just as as
a horror was falling into his catatonic
state. Oh, officially renounced
him breaking into two offshoots.
The majority renamed themselves and leaf.
They set up a fund to compensate oms
victims and swore to become peaceful,
but they never complete these
succeeded in exercising as a horror.
Today there are around
1,500 eleaf members.
Journalists reported that many
who still live surrounded by us,
a Horace teachings,
reading his books and decorating
their homes with portraits of him.
Although under surveillance
by Japanese authorities,
they continue to worship the cultists
to tried to destroy the wells and then
also loan.
In 2016 the tiny European nation of
months and Negro expelled a 58 foreign is
suspected of being members of home,
although forward Japanese,
the majority were Russians.
That same year,
Russian authorities busted 25 compounds
operated by the group of prosecutors of
warms that there may be up to 30,000
Russians currently involved with the cult.
The BBC has since reports.
If the group operating and Bellaruse and
Ukraine shockware Sahara, maybe debt,
but his influence, it clearly
remains. While there's no evidence,
his remaining followers, a
planning, more terrorist atrocities,
they still worship the man who
once brought Tokyo to its knees.
For a man as charismatic as,
as a horror,
it seems his knocked legacy
extends even beyond the grave.
So I already have you found that video.
Interesting.
Hopefully we answered that big.
Who question for you? If you did,
please do give us a thumbs up below
and don't forget to subscribe.
We've got brand new videos several times
a week. So hit that subscribe button,
hit the notification bell.
So you learn about all of those.
If you want something
more right now though,
videos linked to on the screen now
from the archives. And as always,
thank you for watching.